Speaker 1: There's this amazing moment last
night from Fox News where Laura Ingram is
ranting and raving and all of a sudden it
doesn't go well. For Herschel Walker and
she kind of loses it. So first and foremost,
let's go to the moment at which Laura Ingram
is ranting and raving and kind of ginning up
a conspiracy theory of some kind. And then
all of a sudden, it's announced that Herschel
Walker has lost. Check this out, guys.
Speaker 3: We appreciate it,
Bill. Stay with us. All right.
Speaker 1: Sorry. This is not the
right clip. Here is the right clip.
Speaker 3: But why is it that
the heavily Democratic counties
are always the last ones to report?
Speaker 1: Very suspicious, isn't it, Bill Hemmer?
Speaker 3: I mean, presumably they count.
They count. And there are numbers and they
count. There are more people, obviously. But it
seems like it kind of this is I hate to say this
is just a familiar refrain, but it's a very
familiar refrain to us, isn't it? Suspicious
election night past just the midterms, etc..
Speaker 2: I'm going to say that that's
that's where you find the people. That's
where they live. And Laura. Right now,
we're relying on the Associated Press to give us
these numbers. And right now, the Associated Press
is just given the check mark to Raphael Warnock
is going back to the U.S. Senate as the winner
of this runoff against Herschel Walker. Right now
with 50.4% to Walker's 49.6. Raphael Warnock has
won the runoff in Georgia four weeks after CNN.
Speaker 1: But I just love that as Laura Ingraham
is starting to go all conspiratorial, I don't
know. The blue areas take longer to give us
their votes. Sorry, Laura, let me interrupt your
conspiracy to mention that Herschel Walker has
lost this race and Raphael Warnock has won.
Now, later on in the night, a Laura Ingraham
is clearly very worried. And this is this really
is a pleasure to watch. I wanted to start this at
the 125 mark, which is here. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Made and yet nothing seems to be
changing. But you didn't see a lot
of enthusiasm down there. Of course,
the spending was complete. 3 to 1. Yeah,
it was just looking how close it was. So,
I mean, I. And what did we say? This was winnable,
Kelly And I know you don't want any change. Do you
want Ronna McDaniel? I like Ronna McDaniel.
Isn't this like a warning sign flashing or are
we just going to go?
Speaker 1: Laura's
worried and she should be doing.
Speaker 3: The same thing all
over again every single election. Well, Kevin
McCarthy won the House. He won the house. Yes,
he did. And we were outspent 3 to 1 here. Why
no excuse? There's no excuse in Georgia for us
not to have done what Brian Kemp did. Yes. He's
the incumbent governor. He's very popular. He's
running against DC Abrams. But he turned out
over his micro-targeting plan, his grassroots
people. And I guess Mitch McConnell's group
funded it, but they did that in the last couple
of days, weeks ago, did Mitch McConnell.
Speaker 1: All right. So Laura Ingraham
visibly worried. And then it gets a
little tense with Kellyanne Conway.
She is not taking the loss well and she's starting
to take it out on Kellyanne Conway, which I love.
Speaker 3: We don't bank ballots early. We're
going to keep it in this knot. But we didn't
we didn't do it in 2020 because everyone said
don't vote early, because that's what everyone
well well, a lot of people did at the very top
of the Republican Party. Union people did. But
Molly and Mitch McConnell did give 11 million
to the effort. That's 14 million to the effort
in Georgia. But where was the all hands on deck
yet? Lindsey Graham, he was there. He did a lot.
Every senator should have been there. Every
female center should. About why? I'm going to
ask the question tonight. Nobody wants to talk
about this. Why weren't they down there? Right.
Speaker 1: Well, part of it is Herschel Walker
was a disastrous candidate. And Republicans,
as it became clear that the December six runoff
was no longer necessary for Democrats to control
because Democrats were going to control the
Senate either way, once that became clear,
some Republicans who are marginally more tethered
to reality realized this guy's a humiliating
candidate. He can't speak, he can't think he's
a hypocrite. He's going around urging women to
get abortions, even though he says he's against
abortions and he's saying he's a police officer
when he's not and he's saying he trained with
the FBI when he didn't and on and on and on.
Why are they going to hitch their wagon to
this horse? Why are they going to go out on
a limb when either way, they're not going to
have control of the Senate if Herschel Walker
wins? That's why they weren't there. And it was
a complete and total disaster. But, you know,
in a normal country, Walker never would have even
won a primary. He was only even there because of
the atrocity that is the Republican Party. So
a tough night for Laura Ingraham. It is what it
is. Fortunately, we are now beyond this. Democrats
will control 51 to 49. It gives a little bit more.
You know, calmness to some hypothetical scenarios.
Republicans will have the House and we're going
to have an obstruction filled two years. We
will take a quick break. Make sure you were
subscribed on YouTube. It is free. We need your
subscription on YouTube. You can vote multiple
times on YouTube. When it comes to elections,
you can't. You get one vote. Many people have
a couple Google accounts. You can subscribe to
the YouTube channel with each and every account.
It's completely legal. You won't go to jail even
if you get caught. YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. Help us get to 2 million subscribers.
We're going to take a quick break. And I have so
many other things to cover with you today. Folks.
Now is the time as we have gotten beyond the 2022
midterms, 2024 and what are going to be two years
of obstruction are now in focus. We need to build
the ecosystem and the infrastructure. And whether
it's this show or other progressive shows, I would
encourage you support someone that you think is
doing good work. If you want it to be this show,
I'd be flattered and you can sign up at join
Packman dot com. We do an extra show every
single day for our paid members. We offer
a commercial free audio and video stream of
the show custom private podcast URL members
only town halls so many exciting things sign up
at join pacman dot com. You can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a discount.